voilà nous allons maintenant parler du
dernier sujet de ce journal dimanche
c'était dimanche dernier très exactement
nous commencions la semaine des
collections avec un grand couturier
soviétique pour la première fois en
france nous la terminons plus trad et
signer traditionnellement par les robes
de mariées qui en général conclut les
défilés dans ce domaine plus que dans
d'autres il n'est pas facile d'innover
et pourtant cette année leblanc a donné
de l'imagination au créateur nicole
cornu langlois le mariage se porte bien
3 % d'augmentation l'année dernière 400
ont été célébrées dans la mairie de lui
avec eddie barclay comme fidèle client
fantaisie humour liberté totale de style
pour chaque grand couturier dans ce
domaine mini robe pailletée perse pour
laetitia porte le costume de jean louis
scherrer mini robe brodée car d'un
couple de nina ricci robe file rodez
pour l'une costumes satin avec pétales
roses pour l'autre
louis féraud payet diamant et fleurs
pastel philippe venet portant à sa tête
un bouquet prête à me satin pour ted
lapidus le drapé paul se remonte en
capuche pas de mari mais le maire pour
la marier de givenchy en mini robe
brodée de branches du muguet pas de
place pour un marié avec la riche robe
de paco rabanne rebrodé de perles fines
et de fils d'or
à vous de choisir maintenant
superbe